The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Going to
finish up a little bit
from last time on gene
regulatory networks
and see how the different
methods that we looked at
compared, and then we'll
dive into protein interaction
networks.
Were there any questions
from last time?
OK.
Very good.
So recall that we start off with
this dream challenge in which
they provided unlabeled data
representing gene expression
data for either in a completely
synthetic case, in silico data,
or for three different
actual experiments--
one in E. coli, one in S.
cerevisiae, and one in aureus.
For some of those, it was
straight expression data
under different conditions.
In other cases, there were
actual knock-down experiments
or other kinds of perturbations.
And then they gave that
data out to the community
and asked people to use
whatever methods they wanted
to try to rediscover
automatically the gene
regulatory networks.
So with some
preliminary analysis,
we saw that there were a couple
of main clusters of kinds
of analyses that all had similar
properties across these data
sets.
There were the
Bayesian networks,
that we've discussed now
in two separate contexts.
And then we looked at
regression-based techniques
and mutual information
based techniques.
And there were a bunch of
other kinds of approaches.
And some of them actually
combine multiple predictors
from different kinds
of algorithms together.
And some of them, they
evaluated how well each of these
did on all the
different data sets.
So first the results
on the in silico data,
and they're showing
this as an area
under the
precision-recall curve.
Obviously, higher numbers
are going to be better here.
So in this first
group over here are
the regression-based
techniques, mutual information,
correlation, Bayesian networks.
Things didn't fall into any of
those particular categories.
Meta were techniques that
use more than one class
of prediction and then develop
their own prediction based
on those individual techniques.
Then they defined something
that they call the community
definition, which
they combine data
from many of the
different techniques
together with their own
algorithms to kind of come up
with what they call the
"wisdom of the crowds."
And then R represents
a random collection
of other predictions.
And you can see that on
these in silico data,
the performances
don't dramatically
differ one from the other.
Within each class, if you
look at the best performer
in each class, they're all
sort of in the same league.
Obviously, some of the classes
do better consistently.
Now their point
in their analysis
is about the wisdom
of the crowds, that
taking all these data
together, even including
some of the bad
ones, is beneficial.
That's not the main
thing that I wanted
to get out of these
data for our purposes.
So these E. coli data,
notice though that the errant
to the curve, it's about
30 something percent.
Now this is, oh, sorry,
this is in silico data.
Now this is the first
real experimental data
we'll look at, so
this is E. coli data.
And notice the change of scale,
that the best performer's only
doing under less than 10% of
the possible objective optimal
results.
So you can see that the real
data are much, much harder
than the in silico data.
And here the performance
varies quite a lot.
You can see that the Bayesian
networks are struggling,
compared to some of
the other techniques.
The best of those
doesn't really get
close to the best of some
of these other approaches.
So what they did next, was they
took some of the predictions
from their community
predictions that were built off
of all these other data, and
they went and actually tested
some of these.
So they built regulatory
networks for E. coli
and for aureus.
And then they actually did
some experiments to test them.
I think the results
overall are kind
of encouraging, in the
sense that if you focus
on the top pie chart
here, of all the things
that they tested,
about half of them,
they could get some support.
In some cases, it was
very strong support.
In other cases, it
wasn't quite as good.
So the glass is half
empty or half full.
But also, one of the
interesting things
is that the data
are quite variable
over the different
predictions that they make.
So each one of these circles
represents a regulator,
and the things that they claim
are targets of that regulator.
And things that are
in blue are things
that were confirmed
by their experiments.
The things with black outlines
and blue are the controls.
So they knew that
these would be right.
So you could see that for
pure R, they do very well.
For some of these
others, they do mediocre.
But there are some, which
they're honest enough to admit,
they do very poorly on.
So they didn't get any
of their predictions
right for this regulator.
And this probably reflects the
kind of data that they had,
in terms of what conditions
were being tested.
So, so far, things
look reasonable.
I think the real
shocker of this paper
does not appear in the
abstract or the title.
But it is in one of the main
figures, if you pay attention.
So these were the results
for in silico data.
Everything looked pretty good.
Change of scale to E. coli,
there's some variation.
But you can make arguments.
These are the results for
Saccharomyces cerevisiae.
So this is the organism,
yeast, on which
most of the gene
regulatory algorithms
were originally developed.
And people actually
built careers
off of saying how great
their algorithms were
in reconstructing these
regulatory networks.
And we look at these
completely blinded data,
where people don't know
what they're looking for.
You could see that the actual
results are rather terrible.
So the area under the curve
is in the single digits
of percentage.
And it doesn't seem to matter
what algorithm they're using.
They're all doing very badly.
And the community predictions
are no better-- in some cases,
worse-- than the
individual ones.
So this is really
a stunning result.
It's there in the data.
And if you dig into
the supplement,
they actually explain
what's going on, I think,
pretty clearly.
Remember that all
of these predictions
are being made by looking for a
transcriptional regulator that
increases in its own
expression or decreases
in its own expression.
And that change in
its own expression
is predictive of its targets.
So the hypothesis is when you
have more of an activator,
you'll have more of
its targets coming on.
If you have less
of an activator,
you'll have less of the targets.
And you look through
all the data,
whether it's by Bayesian
networks or regression,
to find those kinds
of relationships.
Now what if those
relationships don't actually
exist in the data?
And that's what
this chart shows.
So the green are genes
that have no relationship
with each other.
And they're measuring here the
correlation across all the data
sets, between two
pairs of genes,
for which have no known
regulatory relationship.
The purple are ones
that are targets
of the same
transcription factor.
And the orange
are ones where one
is the activator or
repressor of the other.
And in the in silico data,
they give a very nice spread
between the green, the
orange, and the purple.
So the co-regulator are
very highly correlated
with each other.
The ones that are parent-child
relationships-- a regulator
and its target-- have a
pretty good correlation,
much, much different
from the distribution
that you see for the things
that are not interacting.
And on these data, the
algorithms do their best.
Then you look at
the E. coli data,
and you can see that in
E. Coli, the curves are
much closer to each other,
but there's still some spread.
But when you look
at yeast-- again,
this is where a lot
of these algorithms
were developed-- you
could see there's
almost no difference between the
correlation between the things
that have no relationship
to each other,
things that are co-regulated
by the same regulatory protein,
or those parent-child
relationships.
They're all quite similar.
And it doesn't
matter whether you
use correlation analysis
or mutual information.
Over here and in this
right-hand panel,
they've blown up the
bottom part of this curve,
and you can see how
similar these are.
So again, this is a
mutual information
spread for in silico data for
E. coli and then for yeast.
OK.
So what I think we can say
about the expression analysis
is that expression data
are very, very powerful
for some things and
are going to be rather
poor for some
other applications.
So they're very powerful for
classification and clustering.
We saw that earlier.
Now what those
clusters mean, that's
this inference problem
they're trying to solve now.
And the expression data are
not sufficient to figure out
what the regulatory proteins
are that are causing
those sets of genes to be
co-expressed-- at least
not in yeast.
And I think there's
every expectation
that if you did the
same thing in humans,
you would have the same result.
So the critical
question then is if you
do want to build models of
how regulation is taking place
in organisms, what do you do?
And the answer is that you
need some other kind of data.
So one thing you might
think, if we go back
to this core analysis,
like what's wrong?
Why is it that these gene
expression levels cannot be
used to predict the
regulatory networks?
And it comes down to
whether gene levels are
predictive approaching levels.
And a couple of groups
have looked into this.
One of the earlier studies
was this one, now 2009,
where they used microarray data
and looked at mRNA expression
levels versus protein levels.
And what do you see in this?
You see that there is a trend.
Right there, R
squared is around 0.2,
but that there's a huge spread.
So that for any
position on the x-axis,
a particular level of mRNA, you
can have 1,000-fold variation
in the protein levels.
So a lot of people
saw this and said,
well, we know there are
problems with microarrays.
They're not really great
at predicting mRNA levels
or low in protein levels.
So maybe this will all get
better if we use mRNA-Seq.
Now that turns out
not to be the case.
So there was a very careful
study published in 2012,
where the group used
microarray data, RNA-Seq data,
and a number of different ways
of calling the proteomics data.
So you might say, well,
maybe some of the problem
is that you're not doing a very
good job of inferring protein
levels from mass spec data.
And so they try a whole
bunch of these different ways
of pulling mass spec data.
And then they look,
you should focus
on the numbers in these
columns for the average
and the best correlations
between the RNA
data in these columns and the
proteomic data in the rows.
And you could see the
best case scenario--
you can get these up to 0.54
correlation, still pretty weak.
So what's going on?
What we've been focusing
on now is the idea
that the RNA levels are going
to be very well correlated
with protein levels.
And I think a lot
of literature is
based on hypotheses that
are almost identical.
But in reality, of
course, there are
a lot of processes involved.
There's the process
of translation,
which has a rate
associated with it.
It has regulatory steps
And then there are
degradatory pathways.
So the RNA gets
degraded at some rate,
and the protein gets
degraded at some rate.
And sometimes those
rates are regulated,
sometimes they're not.
Sometimes it depends
on the sequence.
So what would happen
if you actually
measured what's going on?
And that was done recently
in this paper in 2011,
where the group used a
labeling technique for proteins
to [INAUDIBLE] and measure
steady state levels of proteins
and then label the
proteins at specific times
and see how much
newly synthesized
their protein was
at various times.
And similarly, for RNA, using
a technology that allowed them
to separate newly synthesized
transcripts from the bulk RNA.
And once you have
those data, then you
can find out what the spread is
in the half lives of proteins
and the abundance of proteins.
So if you focus on
the left-hand side,
these are the
determined half lives
for various RNAs in blue
and proteins in red.
If you look at the
spread in the red ones,
you've got at least three
orders of magnitude of range
in stability in half
lives for proteins.
So that's really at the
heart of why RNA levels are
very poorly predictive
approaching levels,
because there's such a range
of the stability proteins.
And the RNAs also, they
spread over probably
about one or two orders of
magnitude in the RNA stability.
And then here are
the abundances.
So you can see that
the range of abundance
for average copies
per cell of proteins
is extremely large,
from 100 to 10
to the eighth copies per cell.
Now if you look at the
degradation rates for protein
half lives and RNA
half lives, you
can see there's no correlation.
So these are completely
independent processes
that determine whether an
RNA is degraded or a protein
is degraded.
So then when you try to figure
out what the relationship is
between RNA levels
and protein levels,
you really have to resort to a
set of differential equations
to map out what
all the rates are.
And if you know all
those rates, then you
can estimate what the
relationships will be.
And so they did exactly that.
And these charts show
what they inferred
to be the contribution of
each of these components
to protein levels.
So on the left-hand
side, these are
from cells which
had the most data.
And they build a model
on the same cells
from which they
collected the data.
And in these cells, the RNA
levels account for about 40%
of the protein
levels, the variance.
And the biggest
thing that affects
the abundance of proteins
is rates of translation.
And then they took the data
built from one set of cells
and tried to use it
to predict outcomes
in another set of
cells in replicate.
And the results are
kind of similar.
They also did it for an entirely
different kind of cell types.
In all of these cases,
the precise amounts
are going to vary.
But you can see that
the red bars, which
represent the amount of
information content in the RNA,
is less than about half of what
you can get from other sources.
So this gets back
to why it's so hard
to infer regulatory networks
solely from RNA levels.
So this is the
plot that they get
when they compare
protein levels and RNA
levels at the
experimental level.
And again, you see
that big spread and R
squared at about 0.4,
which at the time,
they were very proud of.
They write several
times in the article,
this is the best anyone
has seen to date.
But if you incorporate all these
other pieces of information
about RNA stability
and protein stability,
you can actually get a
very, very good correlation.
So once you know the variation
in the protein stability
and the RNA stability for each
and every protein and RNA,
then you can do a good job
of predicting protein levels
from RNA levels.
But without all that
data, you can't.
Any questions on this?
So what are we going to do then?
So we really have two primary
things that we can do.
We can try to explicitly model
all of these regulatory steps
and include those in
our predictive models
and try to build up gene
regulatory networks, protein
models that actually include all
those different kinds of data.
And we'll see that
in just a minute.
And the other thing we
can try to do is actually,
rather than try
to focus on what's
downstream of RNA synthesis,
the protein levels,
we can try to focus on what's
upstream of RNA synthesis
and look at what the production
of RNAs-- which RNAs are
getting turned on
and off-- tell us
about the signaling pathways
and the transcription factors.
And that's going to be a
topic of one of the upcoming
lectures in which Professor
Gifford will look at variations
in epigenomic data and
using those variations
in epigenomic data to identify
sequences that represent which
regulatory proteins are bound
under certain conditions
and not others.
Questions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: In a
typical experiment,
the rate constants for how
many mRNAs or proteins can
be estimated?
PROFESSOR: So the question was
how many rate constants can you
estimate in a
typical experiment?
So I should say,
first of all, they're
not typical experiments.
Very few people do
this kind of analysis.
It's actually very time
consuming, very expensive.
So I think in this one, it was--
I'll get the numbers roughly
wrong-- but it was thousands.
It was some decent fraction
of the proteome, but not
the entire one.
But most of the data
set's papers you'll read
do not include any analysis of
stability rates, degradation
rates.
They only look at the bulk
abundance of the RNAs.
Other questions?
OK.
So this is an
upcoming lecture where
we're going to actually
try to go backwards.
We're going to say, we
see these changes in RNA.
What does that
tell us about what
regulatory regions of the
genome were active or not?
And then you could
go upstream from that
and try to figure out
the signaling pathways.
So if I know
changes in RNA, I'll
deduce, as we'll see in
that upcoming lecture--
the sequences-- the identity
of the DNA binding proteins.
And then I could
try to figure out
what the signaling
pathways were that drove
those changes in
gene expression.
Now later in this lecture, we'll
talk about the network modeling
problem.
If assuming you knew these
transcription factors,
what could you do to
infer this network?
But before we go
to that, I'd like
to talk about an interesting
modeling approach that
tries to take into account
all these degradatory pathways
and look specifically at
each kind of regulation
as an explicit step in
the model and see how that
copes with some of these issues.
So this is work
from Josh Stewart.
And one of the first
papers is here.
We'll look at some
later ones as well.
And the idea here is to
explicitly, as I said,
deal with many, many
different steps in regulation
and try to be quite specific
about what kinds of data
are informing about what
step in the process.
So we measure the
things in the bottom
here-- arrays that tell us
how many copies of a gene
there are in the genome,
especially in cancer.
And you can get
big changes of what
are called copy number,
amplifications, or deletions
of large chunks of chromosomes.
You need to take
that into account.
All the RNA-Seq and microarrays
that we were talking about
in measuring
transcription levels--
what do they actually tell us?
Well, they give us
some information
about what they're
directly connected to.
So the transcriptomic data tells
something about the expression
state.
But notice they have explicitly
separated the expression
state of the RNA from
the protein level.
And they separated
the protein level
from the protein activity.
And they have these
little black boxes in here
that represent the different
kinds of regulations.
So however many copies of a
gene you have in the genome,
there's some regulatory event,
transcriptional regulation,
that determines how
much expression you
get at the mRNA level.
There's another
regulatory event here
that determines at what
rate those RNAs are
turned into proteins.
And there are other
regulatory steps here
that have to do with
signaling pathways,
for example, that determine
whether those proteins are
active or not.
So we're going to treat each
of those as separate variables
in our model that
are going to be
connected by these black boxes.
So they call their
algorithm "Paradigm,"
and they developed
it in the context
of looking at cancer data.
In cancer data, the two primary
kinds of information they had
were the RNA levels from either
microarray or RNA-Seq and then
these copy number
variations, again,
representing
amplifications or deletions
of chunks of the genome.
And what they're trying
to infer from that
is how active different
components are of
known signaling pathways.
Now the approach that
they used that involved
all of those little
black boxes is something
called a factor graph.
And factor graphs can be
thought of in the same context
as Bayesian networks.
In fact, Bayesian networks
are a type of factor graph.
So if I have a
Bayesian network that
represents these three
variables, where they're
directly connected by
edges, in a factor graph,
there would be this extra
kind of node-- this black box
or red box-- that's the factor
that's going to connect them.
So what do these things do?
Well, again, they're
bipartite graphs.
They always have these
two different kinds
of nodes-- the random
variables and the factors.
And the reason they're
called factor graphs is they
describe how the global
function-- in our case,
it's going to be the global
probability distribution--
can be broken down into
factorable components.
It can be combined
in a product to look
at what the global
probability function is.
So if I have some
global function over all
the variables, you can think
of this again, specifically,
as the probability function--
the joint probability for all
the variables in my system--
I want to be able to divide it
into a product of
individual terms,
where I don't have all the
variables in each of these f's.
They're just some
subset of variables.
And each of these represents
one of these terms
in that global product.
The only things that
are in this function,
are things to which
it's directly connected.
So these edges exist
solely between a factor
and the variables that are
terms in that equation.
Is that clear?
So in this context,
the variables
are going to be nodes.
And their allowed
values are going
to be whether they're
activated or not activated.
The factors are going to
describe the relationships
among those variables.
We previously saw those as
being cases of regulation.
Is the RNA turned into protein?
Is the protein activated?
And what we'd like
to be able do is
compute marginal probabilities.
So we've got some
big network that
represents our understanding
of all the signaling pathways
and all the transcriptional
regulatory networks in a cancer
cell.
And we want to ask about
a particular pathway
or a particular protein,
what's the probability
that this protein or this
pathway is activated,
marginalized over all
the other variables?
So that's our goal.
Our goal is to find
a way to compute
these marginal
probabilities efficiently.
And how do you
compute a marginal?
Well, obviously you need to
sum over all the configurations
of all the variables that
have your particular variable
at its value.
So if I want to know if
MYC and MAX are active,
I set MYC and MAX
equal to active.
And then I sum over
all the configurations
that are consistent with that.
And in general, that
would be hard to do.
But the factor graph
gives us an efficient way
of figuring out how to do that.
I'll show you in a second.
So I have some global function.
In this case, this little
factor graph over here,
this is the global function.
Now remember, these
represent the factors,
and they only have
edges to things
that are terms in
their equations.
So over here, is a
function of x3 and x5.
And so it has edges to x3 and
x5, and so on for all of them.
And if I want to explicitly
compute the marginal
with respect to a
particular variable,
so the marginal
with respect to x1
set equal to a, so I'd
have this function with x1
equal to a times the sum over
all possible states of x2,
the sum over all possible
states of x3, x4, and x5.
Is that clear?
That's just the
definition of a marginal.
They introduced a notation in
factor graphs that's called
a "not-sum."
It's rather terrible, but
the not-sum or summary.
So I like this term,
summary, better.
The summary over
all the variables.
So if I want to figure
out the summary for x1,
that's the sum over
all the other variables
of all their
possible states when
I set x1 equal to
a, in this case.
So it's purely a definition.
So then I can rewrite-- and you
can work this through by hand
after class-- but
I can rewrite this,
which is this intuitive way
of thinking of the marginal,
in terms of these not-sums,
where each one of these
is over all the other
variables that are not
the one that's in the brackets.
So that's just the definition.
OK, this hasn't really
helped us very much,
if we don't have
some efficient way
of computing these marginals.
And that's what the
factor graph does.
So we've got some factor graph.
We have this
representation, either
in terms of graph or equation,
of how the global function can
be partitioned.
Now if I take any one
of these factor graphs,
and I want to compute
a marginal over a node,
I can re-draw the factor graph
so that variable of interest
is the root node.
Right?
Everyone see that these
two representations
are completely equivalent?
I've just yanked
x1 up to the top.
So now this is a tree structure.
So this is that factor
graph that we just
saw drawn as a tree.
And this is what's called
an expression tree, which
is going to tell
us how to compute
the marginal over the
structure of the graph.
So this is just copied
from the previous picture.
And now we're going to come up
with a program for computing
these marginals, using
this tree structure.
So first I'm going to compute
that summary function--
the sum over all sets of the
other variables for everything
below this point, starting with
the lowest point in the graph.
And we can compute the
summary function there.
And that's this term, the
summary for x3 of just this fE.
I do the same thing for
fD, the summary for it.
And then I go up a
level in the tree,
and I multiply the summary
for everything below it.
So I'm going to compute
the product of the summary
functions.
And I always compute the summary
with respect to the parent.
So here the parent was
x3, for both of these.
So these are summaries
with respect to x3.
Here who's the parent?
x1.
And so the summary is to x1.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are there
directed edges?
In the sense that in f, in
the example on the right,
is fD just relating
how x4 relates to x3?
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
So the edges represent which
factor you're related to.
So that's why I can
redraw it in any way.
I'm always going to
go from the leaves up.
I don't have to worry about any
directed edges in the graph.
Other questions.
So what this does
is it gives us a way
to officially, overall a
complicated graph structure,
compute marginals.
And they're typically
thought of in terms
of messages that are being sent
from the bottom of the graph up
to the top.
And you can have a rule from
computing these marginals.
And the rule is as follows.
Each vertex waits
for the messages
from all of its
children, until it
gets its-- the messages are
accumulating their way up
the graph.
And every node is
waiting until it
hears from all of its progeny
about what's going on.
And then it sends the signal
up above it to its parent,
based on the following rules.
A variable node just takes
the product of the children.
And a factor node-- one of
those little black boxes--
computes the summary
for the children
and sends that up to the parent.
And it's the summary with
respect to the parent,
just like in the
examples before.
So this is a formula for
computing single marginals.
Now it turns out-- I'm not going
to go into details of this.
It's kind of complicated.
But you actually can,
based on this core idea,
come up with an efficient way of
computing all of the marginals
without having to
do this separately
for every single one.
And that's called a
message passing algorithm.
And if you're really
interested, you
can look into the citation
for how that's done.
So the core idea is that we
can take a representation
of our belief of how this
global function-- in our case,
it's going to be the joint
probability-- factors in terms
of particular
biological processes.
We can encode what we know about
the regulation in that factor
graph, the structure
of the graph.
And then we could
have an efficient way
of computing the marginals,
which will tell us,
given the data,
what's the probability
that this particular
pathway is active?
So in this particular case,
in this paradigm model,
the variables can
take three states--
activated, deactivated,
or unchanged.
And this is, in a tumor
setting, for example,
you might say the tumor is
just like the wild type cell,
or the tumor has activation
with respect to the wild type,
or it has a repression with
respect to the wild type.
Again, this is the structure of
the factor graph that they're
using and the different kinds
of information that they have.
The primary experimental
data are just
these arrays that tell us about
SNiPs and copy number variation
and then arrays or RNA-Seq to
tell us about the transcript
levels.
But now they can
encode all sorts
of rather complicated
biological functions
in the graph structure itself.
So transcription
regulation is shown here.
Why is the edge from
activity to here?
Because we don't
want to just infer
that if there's more of the
protein, there's more activity.
So we're actually,
explicitly computing
the activity of each protein.
So if an RNA gets
transcribed, it's
because some transcription
factor was active.
And the transcription
factor might not
be active, even if the levels
of the transcription factor
are high.
That's one of the
pieces that's not
encoded in all of those
things that were in the dream
challenge, that are really
critical for representing
the regulatory structure.
Similarly, protein
activation-- I
can have protein that goes from
being present to being active.
So think of a
kinase, that itself
needs to be phosphorylated
to be active.
So that would be
that transition.
Some other kinase comes in.
And if that other
kinase1 is active,
then it can
phosphorylate kinase2
and make that one active.
And so it's pretty
straightforward.
You can also represent the
formation of a complex.
So the fact that all the
proteins are in the cell
doesn't necessarily mean they're
forming an active complex.
So the next step
then can be here.
Only when I have
all of them, would I
have activity of the complex.
We'll talk about how AND-like
connections are formed.
And then they also
can incorporate OR.
So what does that mean?
So if I know that all
members of the gene family
can do something, I might
want to explicitly represent
that gene family as an element
to the graph-- a variable.
Is any member of
this family active?
And so that would be
done this way, where
if you have an OR-like
function here, then
this factor would make this gene
active if any of the parents
are active.
So there, they
give a toy example,
where they're trying to figure
out if the P53 pathway is
active, so MDM2 is
an inhibitor of P53.
P53 can be an
activator-related apoptosis.
And so for separately,
for MDM2 and for P53,
they have the factor graphs
that show the relationship
between copy number
variation and transcript
level and protein
level and activity.
And those relate to each other.
And then those relate to
the apoptotic pathway.
So what they want to do
then is take the data
that they have, in
terms of these pathways,
and they want to compute
the likelihood ratios.
What's the probability
of observing
the data, given a hypothesis
that this pathway is active
and all my other settings
of the parameters?
And compare that
to the probability
of the data, given that
that pathway is not active.
So this is the kinds
of likelihood ratios
we've been seeing now
in a couple of lectures.
So now it gets into the details
of how you actually do this.
So there's a lot of manual
steps involved here.
So if I want to encode a
regulatory pathway as a factor
graph, it's currently done in a
manual way or semi-manual way.
You convert what's
in the databases
into the structure
or factor graph.
And you make a
series of decisions
about exactly how
you want to do that.
You can argue with the
particular decisions
they made, but the
reasonable ones.
People could do
things differently.
So they convert the regulatory
networks into graphs.
And then they have to
define some of the functions
on this graph.
So they define the expected
state of a variable,
based on the state
of its parents.
And they take a majority
vote of the parents.
So a parent that's connected by
a positive edge, meaning it's
an activator, if the
parent is active,
then it contributes a
plus 1 to the child.
If it's connected by
a repressive edge,
then the parenting active
would make a vote of minus 1
for the child.
And you take the majority
vote of all those votes.
So that's what this says.
But the nice thing is that you
can also incorporate logic.
So for example, when
we said, is any member
of this pathway active?
And you have a
family member node.
So that can be done
with an OR function.
And there, it's
these same factors
that will determine--
so some of these edges
are going to get
labeled "maximum"
or "minimum," that
tell you what's
the expected value of the
child, based on the parent.
So if it's an OR, then if any
of the parents are active,
then the child is active.
And if it's AND, you
need all of them.
So you could have described
all of these networks
by Bayesian networks.
But the advantage
of a factor graph
is that your explicitly
able to include
all these steps to describe this
regulation in an intuitive way.
So you can go back
to your models
and understand what
you've done, and change it
in an obvious way.
Now critically, we're
not trying to learn
the structure of the
graph from the data.
We're imposing the
structure of the graph.
We still need to learn
a lot of variables,
and that's done using
expectation maximization,
as we saw in the
Bayesian networks.
And then, again,
it's a factor graph,
which primarily means that we
can factor the global function
into all of these factor nodes.
So the total probability
is normalized,
but it's the product
of these factors which
have to do with just the
variables that are connected
to that factor
node in the graph.
And this notation
that you'll see
if you look through
this, this notation
means the setting
of all the variables
consistent with something.
So let's see that-- here we go.
So this here, this is the
setting of all the variables
X, consistent with the data
that we have-- so the data
being the arrays, the
RNA-Seq, if you had it.
And so we want to compute
the marginal probability
of some particular variable
being at a particular setting,
given the fully
specified factor graph.
And we just take the product
of all of these marginals.
Is that clear?
Consistent with all
the settings where
that variable is
set to x equals a.
Questions?
OK.
And we can compute the
likelihood function
in the same way.
So then what actually happens
when you try to do this?
So they give an example here in
this more recent paper, where
it's basically a toy example.
But they're modeling all
of these different states
in the cells.
So G are the number
of genomic copies,
T, the level of transcripts.
Those are connected by a factor
to what you actually measure.
So there is some true
change in the number
of copies in the cell.
And then there's what
appears in your array.
There's some true number of
copies of RNA in the cell.
And then there's what you
get out of your RNA-Seq.
So that's what these
factors are present--
and then these are
regulatory terms.
So how much transcript you get
depends on these two variables,
the epigenetic state
of the promoter
and the regulatory proteins
that interact with it.
How much transcript
gets turned into protein
depends on regulatory proteins.
And those are determined by
upstream signaling events.
And how much protein
becomes active,
again, is determined by the
upstream signaling events.
And then those can have effects
on downstream pathways as well.
So then in this toy example,
they're looking at MYC/MAX.
They're trying to figure out
whether it's active or not.
So we've got this pathway.
PAK2 represses MYC/MAX.
MYC/MAX activates these two
genes and represses this one.
And so if these were
the data that we
had coming from copy number
variation, DNA methylation,
and RNA expression, then I'd
see that the following states
of the downstream genes--
this one's active.
This one's repressed.
This one's active.
They infer that
MYC/MAX is active.
Oh, but what about the fact
that this one should also
be activated?
That can be explained
away by the fact
that there's a difference in the
epigenetic state between ENO1
and the other two.
And then the belief
propagation allows
us to transfer that information
upward through the graph
to figure out, OK, so now we've
decided that MYC/MAX is active.
And that gives us information
about the state of the proteins
upstream of it and the
activity then of PAK2,
which is a repressor of MYC/MAX.
Questions on the factor
graphs specifically
or anything's that
come up until now?
So this has all been
reasoning on known pathways.
One of the big promises of
these systematic approaches
is the hope that we can
discover new pathways.
Can we discover things we
don't already know about?
And for this, we're going to
look at interactome graphs,
so graphs that are
built primarily
from high throughput
protein-protein interaction
data, but could also
be built, as we'll see,
from other kinds of
large-scale connections.
And we're going to look
at what the underlying
structure of these
networks could be.
And so they could
arise from a graph
where you put an edge
between two nodes
if their co-expressed, if they
have high mutual information.
That's what we saw
in say, ARACHNE,
which we talked
about a lecture ago.
Or, if say, the two hybrids
and affinity capture mass spec
indicated direct
physical interaction
or say a high throughput
genetic screen
indicated a genetic interaction.
These are going to be
very, very large graphs.
And we're going to look at some
of the algorithmic problems
that we have dealing
with huge graphs
and how to compress the
information down so we get
some piece of the network
that's quite interpretable.
And we'll look at
various kinds of ways
of analyzing these graphs
that are listed here.
So one of the advantages of
dealing with data in the graph
formulation is that we can
leverage the fact that computer
science has dealt with large
graphs for quite a while
now, often in the context
of telecommunications.
Now big data, Facebook,
Google-- they're always
dealing with things in
a graph formulation.
So there are a lot of algorithms
that we can take advantage of.
We're going to look at
how to use quick distance
calculations on graphs.
And we'll look at that
specifically in an example
of how to find the kinase
target relationships.
Then we'll look at how
to cluster large graphs
to find subgraphs
that either represents
an interesting
topological feature
of the inherent
structure of the graph
or perhaps to represent
active pieces of the network.
And then we'll look at
other kinds of optimization
techniques to help us find
the part of the network that's
most relevant to our particular
experimental setting.
So let's start with
ostensibly a simple problem.
I know a lot about-- I have a
lot of protein phosphorylation
data.
I'd like to figure
out what kinase
was that phosphorylated
a particular protein.
So let's say I have
this protein that's
involved in cancer
signaling, Rad50.
And I know it's phosphorylated
these two sites.
And I have the sequences
of those sites.
So what kinds of tools do
we have at our disposal
if I have a set of
sequences that I believe
are phosphorylated,
that would help
me try to figure out what
kinase did the phosphorylation?
Any ideas?
So if I know the specificity of
the kinases, what could I do?
I could look for
a sequence match
between the specificity
of the kinase
and the sequence of
the protein, right?
In the same way that
we can look for a match
between the specificity
of a transcription factor
and the region of the
genome to which it binds.
So if I have a library
of specificity motifs
for different kinases,
where every position here
represents a piece of
the recognition element,
and the height of the letters
represent the information
content, I can scan those.
And I can see what
family of kinases
are most likely to be
responsible for phosphorylating
these sites.
But again, those are
families of kinases.
There are many
individual members
of each of those families.
So how to I find
the specific member
of that family that's
most likely to carry out
the regulation?
So here, what happens
in this paper.
It's called [? "Network." ?]
And as they say, well,
let's use the graph properties.
Let's try to figure out which
proteins are physically linked
relatively closely in the
network to the target.
So in this case, they've
got Rad50 over here.
And they're trying to figure out
which kinase is regulating it.
So here are two kinases that
have similar specificity.
But this one's
directly connected
in the interaction
that works so it's
more likely to be responsible.
And here's the member
of the kinase that
seems to be consistent with the
sequence being phosphorylated
over here.
It's not directly connected,
but it's relatively close.
And so that's also a
highly probable member,
compared to one that's
more distantly related.
So in general, if I've
got a set of kinases
that are all of equally good
sequence matches to the target
sequence, represented by these
dash lines, but one of them
is physically linked as well,
perhaps directly and perhaps
indirectly, I have
higher confidence
in this kinase because
of its physical links
than I do in these.
So that's fine if you want
to look at things one by one.
But if you want to look
at this at a global scale,
we need very
efficient algorithms
for figuring out what the
distance is in this interaction
network between any
kinase and any target.
So how do you go about
officially computing distances?
Well that's where converting
things into a graph structure
is helpful.
So when we talk
about graphs here,
we mean sets of vertices and
the edges that connect them.
The vertices, in our case,
are going to be proteins.
The edges are going
to perhaps represent
physical interactions or some
of these other kinds of graphs
we talked about.
These graphs can be directed,
or they can the undirected.
Undirected would be what?
For example, say two hybrid.
I don't know which one's
doing what to which.
I just know that two
proteins can come together.
Whereas a directed edge
might be this kinase
phosphorylates this target.
And so it's a directed edge.
I can have weights
associated with these edges.
We'll see in a
second how we can use
that to encode our confidence
that the edge represents
a true physical interaction.
We can also talk about the
degree, the number of edges
that come into a
node or leave a node.
And for our point,
it's rather important
to talk about the path,
the set of vertices
that can get me from one
node to another node,
without ever retracing my steps.
And we're going to
talk about path length,
so if my graph is
unweighted, that's
just the number of
edges along the path.
But if my graph
has edge weights,
it's going to be the sum of the
edge weights along that path.
Is that clear?
And then we're going to
use an adjacency matrix
to represent the graphs.
So I have two completely
equivalent formulations
of the graph.
One is the picture on
the left-hand side,
and the other one is the matrix
on the right-hand side, where
a 1 between any row
and column represents
the presence of an edge.
So the only edge connecting
node 1 goes to node 2.
Whereas, node 2 is connected
both to node 1 and to node 3.
Hopefully, that agrees.
OK.
Is that clear?
And if I have a weighted
graph, then instead
of putting zeros or
ones in the matrix,
I'll put the actual edge
weights in the matrix.
So there are algorithms that
exist for officially finding
shortest paths in large graphs.
So we can very
rapidly, for example,
compute the shortest path
between any two nodes,
based solely on that
adjacency matrix.
Now why are we going to
look at weighted graphs?
Because that gives us the
way to encode our confidence
in the underlying data.
So because the total
distance in network
is the sum of the edge weights,
if I set my edge weights
to be negative log
of a probability,
then if I sum all
the edge weights,
I'm taking the product of
all those probabilities.
And so the shortest
path is going
to be the most probable
path as well, because it's
going to be the minimum of
the sum of the negative log.
So it's going to be the maximum
of the joint probability.
Is that clear?
OK.
Very good.
So by encoding our network as a
weighted graph, where the edge
weights are minus log
of the probability,
then when I use these standard
algorithms for finding
the shortest path
between any two nodes,
I'm also getting the most
probable path between these two
proteins.
So where these edge
weights come from?
So if my network consists
say of affinity capture mass
spec and two hybrid
interactions,
how would I compute the edge
of weights for that network?
We actually explicitly
talked about this
just a lecture or two ago.
So I have all this
affinity capture mass spec,
two hybrid data.
And I want to
assign a probability
to every edge that tells me how
confident I am that it's real.
So we already saw that in
the context of this paper
where we use Bayesian networks
and gold standards to compute
the probability for every
single edge in the interactome.
OK.
So that works pretty well if you
can define the gold standards.
It turns out that that has
not been the most popular way
of dealing with mammalian data.
It works pretty well
for yeast, but it's not
what's used primarily
in mammalian data.
So in mammalian data, the
databases are much larger.
The number of gold
standards are fewer.
People rely on more
ad hoc methods.
One of the big advances,
technically, for the field
was the development of a common
way for all these databases
of protein-protein interactions
to report their data,
to be able to interchange them.
There's something called
PSICQUIC and PSISCORE, that
allow a client to
pull information
from all the different
databases of protein-protein
interactions.
And because you can get all
the data in a common format
where it's traceable back to
the underlying experiment,
then you can start
computing confidence scores
based on these
properties, what we
know about where the data came
from in a high throughput way.
Different people have
different approaches
to computing those scores.
So there's a common
format for that
as well, which is
this PSISCORE where
you can build your interaction
database from whichever
one of these underlying
databases you want,
filter it however you want.
And then send your database to
one of these scoring servers.
And they'll send
you back the scores
according to their algorithm.
One that I kind of like this
is this Miscore algorithm.
It digs down into
the underlying data
of what kind of
experiments were done
and how many
experiments were done.
Again, they make all sorts
of arbitrary decisions
in how they do that.
But the arbitrary
decisions seem reasonable
in the absence of
any other data.
So their scores are based on
these three kinds of terms--
how many publications
there are associated
with any interaction, what
experimental method was used,
and then also, if there's an
annotation in the database
saying that we know that this
is a genetic interaction,
or we know that it's a
physical interaction.
And then they put weights
on all of these things.
So people can argue
about what the best
way of approaching this is.
The fundamental point
is that we can now
have a very, very
large database of known
interactions as weighted.
So by last count,
there are about 250,000
protein-protein interactions
for humans in these databases.
So you have that
giant interactome.
It's got all these scores
associated with it.
And now we can dive
into that and say,
these data are somewhat largely
unbiased by our prior notions
about what's important.
They're built up from
high throughput data.
So unlike the carefully
curated pathways
that are what everybody's
been studying for decades,
there might be information
here about pathways
no one knows about.
Can we find those pathways
in different contexts?
What can we learn from that?
So one early thing
people can do is just
try to find pieces
of the network that
seem to be modular,
where there are
more interactions among the
components of that module
than they are to other
pieces of the network.
And you can find those
modules in two different ways.
One is just based on
the underlying network.
And one is based on the
network, plus some external data
you have.
So one would be
to say, are there
proteins that fundamentally
interact with each other
under all possible settings?
And then we would say, in
my particular patient sample
or my disease or
my microorganism,
which proteins seem
to be functioning
in this particular condition?
So one is the topological model.
That's just the network itself.
And one is the functional model,
where I layer onto information
that the dark nodes are active
in my particular condition.
So an early use of
this kind of approach
was to try to annotate
nodes-- a large fraction
of even well studied
genomes that we don't know
the function of
any of those genes.
So what if I use the
structure of the network
to infer that if some protein
is close to another protein
in this interaction
network, it is
likely to have similar function?
And statistically,
that's definitely true.
So this graph shows, for things
for where we know the function,
the semantic similarity
in the y-axis,
the distance in the
network in the x-axis,
things that are close to
each other in the network
of interactions, are
also more likely to be
similar in terms of function.
So how do we go
about doing that?
So let's say we
have got this graph.
We've got some unknown
node labeled u.
And we've got two
known nodes in black.
And we want to systematically
deduce for every example
like this, every u, what
its annotation should be.
So I could just look
at its neighbors,
and depending on how I
set the window around it,
do I look at the
immediate neighbors?
Do I go two out?
Do I go three out?
I could get different answers.
So if I set K equal to 1,
I've got the unknown node,
but all the neighbors
are also unknown.
If I go two steps out,
then I pick up two knowns.
Now there's a fundamental
assumption going on here
that the node has the same
function as its neighbors,
which is fine when the
neighbors are homogeneous.
But what do you do when the
neighbors are heterogeneous?
So in this case, I've
got two unknowns u and v.
And if I just were to take
the K nearest neighbors,
they would have the same
neighborhood, right?
But I might have a prior
expectation that u is more like
the black nodes, and v is
more like the grey nodes.
So how do you choose
the best annotation?
The K nearest neighbors is
OK, but it's not the optimal.
So here's one approach,
which says the following.
I'm going to go through
for every function,
every annotation in my
database, separately.
And for each annotation,
I'll set all the nodes that
have that annotation to
plus 1 and every node
that doesn't have that
annotation, either it's unknown
or it's got some other
annotation, to minus 1.
And then for every
unknown, I'm going
to try to find the
setting which is going
to maximize the sum of products.
So we're going to take the
sum of the products of u
and all of its neighbors.
So in this setting,
if I set u to plus 1,
then I do better than if I
set it to minus 1, right?
Because I'll get plus
1 plus 1 minus 1.
So that will be better
than setting it to minus 1.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are we ignoring
all the end weights?
PROFESSOR: In this case, we're
ignoring the end weights.
We'll come back to using
the end weights later.
But this was done with
an unweighted graph.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? nearest neighborhood ?]
they're using it then?
PROFESSOR: So here they're
using the nearest neighbors.
That's right, with
no cutoff, right?
So any interaction.
So then we could iterate
this into convergence.
That's one problem with this.
But maybe a more
fundamental problem
is that you're never going to
get the best overall solution
by this local
optimization procedure.
So consider a setting like this.
Remember, I'm trying
to maximize the sum
of the product of the
settings for neighbors.
So how could I ever-- it seems
plausible that all A, B, and C
here, should have the
red annotation, right?
But if I set C to red,
that doesn't help me.
If I set A to red,
If I set B to red, it
makes things worse.
So no local change is going
to get me where I want to go.
So let's think for a second.
What algorithms
have we already seen
that could help us get
to the right answer?
We can't get here by
local optimization.
We need to find the global
minimum, not the local minimum.
So what algorithms
have we seen that
help us find that
global minimum?
Yeah, sorry, so a video
simulated annealing.
So the simulated annealing
version in this setting
is as follows.
I initialize the graph.
I pick a neighboring node,
v, that I'm going to add.
Say we'll turn one of these red.
I check the value of that sum of
the products for this new one.
And if it's improving
things, I keep it.
But the critical thing
is, if it doesn't improve,
if it makes things
worse, I still
keep it with some probability.
It's based on how bad
things have gotten.
And by doing this,
we can climb the hill
and get over to
some global optimum.
So we saw simulating before.
In what context?
When in the side chain
placement problem.
Here we're seeing it again.
It's quite broad.
Any time you've got a
local optimization that
doesn't get you
where you need to go,
you need global optimization.
You can think
simulated annealing.
It's quite often the
plausible way to go.
All right.
So this is one approach
for annotation.
We also wanted to see
whether we could discover
inherent structure
in these graphs.
So often, we'll be
interested in trying
to find clusters in a graph.
Some graphs have obvious
structures in them.
Other graphs, it's a
little less obvious.
What algorithms exist
for trying to do this?
We're going to look at two
relatively straightforward
ways.
One is called edge
betweenness clustering
and the other one
is a Markov process.
Edge betweenness, I think,
is the most intuitive.
So I look at each
edge, and I ask
for all pairs of
nodes in the graph,
does the shortest path
between those nodes
pass through this edge?
So if I look at this edge,
very few shortest paths
go through this edge, right?
Just the shortest path
for those two nodes.
But if I look at this edge,
all of the shortest paths
between any node on this side
and any node on this side
have to pass through there.
So that has a high betweenness.
So if I want a cluster, I
can go through my graph.
I can compute betweenness.
I take the edge that has
the highest betweenness,
and I remove it from my graph.
And then I repeat.
And I'll be slowly
breaking my graph down
into chunks that are relatively
more connected internally
than they are to
things in other pieces.
Any questions?
So that's an entire
edge betweenness
clustering algorithm.
Pretty straightforward.
Now an alternative is a
Markov clustering method.
And the Markov
clustering method is
based on the idea of
random walks in the graph.
So again, let's try to
develop some intuition here.
If I start at some
node over here,
and I randomly wander
across this graph,
I'm more likely to stay
on the left-hand side
than I am to move all the way
across to the right-hand side,
correct?
So can I formalize that
and actually come up
with a measure of how
often any node will visit
any other and then use
that to cluster the graph?
So remember our
adjacency matrix,
which just represented which
nodes were connected to which.
And what happens if I multiply
the adjacency matrix by itself?
So I raise it to some power.
Well, if I multiply the
adjacency matrix by itself
just once, the squared adjacency
matrix of the property,
that it tells me how
many paths of length 2
exists between any two nodes.
So the adjacency matrix told
me how many paths of length 1
exist.
Right?
You're directly connected.
If I squared the
adjacency matrix,
it tells me how many
paths of length 2 exist.
N-th power tells me how many
paths of length N exist.
So let's see if that works.
This claims that
there are exactly
two paths that connect
node 2 to node 2.
What are those two paths?
Connect node 2 to node 2.
I go here, and I go back.
That's the path of length 2, and
this is the path of length 2.
And there are zero
paths of length 2
that connect node 2 to
node three, because 1, 2.
I'm not back at 3.
So that's from general
A to the N equals m,
if there exists exactly m paths
of length N between those two
nodes.
So how does this help me?
Well, when you take that idea of
the N-th power of the adjacency
matrix and convert it to a
transition probability matrix,
simply by normalizing.
So if I were to do a
random walk in this graph,
what's the probability
that I'll move from node i
to node j in a certain
number of steps?
That's what I want to compute.
So I need to have a
stochastic matrix,
where the sum of
the probabilities
for any transition is 1.
I have to end up somewhere.
I either end up back
in myself, or I end up
at some other nodes.
I'm just going to take
that adjacency matrix
and normalize the columns.
And then that gives me
the stochastic matrix.
And then I can exponentiate
the stochastic matrix
to figure out my probability
of moving from any node
to any other in a
certain number of steps.
Any questions on that?
OK.
So if we simply keep multiplying
this stochasticity matrix,
we'll get the probability of
increasing numbers of moves.
But it doesn't give us sharp
partitions of the matrix.
So to do a Markov clustering,
we do an exponentiation
of this matrix with
what's called an inflation
operator, which
is the following.
This inflation operator
takes the r-th power
of the adjacency matrix
and puts a denominator,
the sum of the powers
of the transition.
So here's an example.
Let's say I've got two
probabilities-- 0.9 and 0.1.
When I inflate it, I
square the numerator,
and I square each element
of the denominator.
Now I've gone from 0.9
to 0.99 and 0.1 to 0.01.
So this inflation
operator exaggerates
all my probabilities and makes
the higher probabilities more
probable and makes the lower
probabilities even less
probable.
So I take this
adjacency matrix that
represents the number
of steps in my matrix,
and I exaggerate it with
the inflation operator.
And that takes the
basic clustering,
and it makes it more compact.
So the algorithm for this
Markov clustering is as follows.
I start with a graph.
I add loops to the graph.
Why do I add loops?
Because I need some probability
that I stay in the same place,
right?
And in a normal
adjacency matrix,
you can't stay in
the same place.
You have to go somewhere.
So I add a loop.
So there's always a self loop.
Then I set the inflation
parameter to some value.
M_1 is the matrix of random
walks in the original graph.
I multiply that.
I inflate it.
And then I find the difference.
And I do that until the
difference in this--
because this matrix
gets below some value.
And what I end up with then
are relatively sharp partitions
of the overall structure.
So I'll show you an
example of how that works.
So in this case,
the authors were
using a matrix where the
nodes represented proteins.
The edges represented
BLAST hits.
And what they wanted
to do was find
families of proteins
that had similar sequence
similarity to each other.
But they didn't want it to be
entirely dominated by domains.
So they figured that this graph
structure would be helpful,
because you'd get--
for any protein,
there'd be edges,
not just things
that had similar common
domains, but also things that
had edges connecting it
to other proteins as well.
So in the original graph, the
edges are these BLAST values.
They come up with the
transition matrix.
They convert into
the Markov matrix,
and they carry out
that exponentiation.
And what they end
up with are clusters
where any individual domain
can appear multiple clusters.
The domains are dominated not
just by the highest BLAST hit,
but by the whole network
property of what other proteins
they're connected to.
And it's also been done with a
network, where the underlying
network represents
gene expression,
and edges between two
genes represent the degree
of correlation of the expression
across a very large data
set for 61 mouse tissues.
And once again, you
take the overall graph,
and you can break it
down into clusters,
where you can find
functional annotations
for specific clusters.
Any questions then on
the Markov clustering?
So these are two
separate ways of looking
at the underlying
structure of a graph.
We had the edge betweenness
clustering and the Markov
clustering.
Now when you do this, you
have to make some decision,
as I found this cluster.
Now how do I decide
what it's doing?
So you need to do some
sort of annotation.
So once I have a
cluster, how am I
going to assign a
function to that cluster?
So one thing I could
do would be to look
at things that already
have an annotation.
So I got some cluster.
Maybe two members
of this cluster
have an annotation and
two members of this one.
And that's fine.
But what do I do
when a cluster has
a whole bunch of
different annotations?
So I could be arbitrary.
I could just take the one
that's the most common.
But a nice way to do it is by
the hypergeometric distribution
that you saw in the earlier
part of the semester.
So these are all ways of
clustering the underlying graph
without any reference
to specific data
for a particular condition
that you're interested in.
A slightly harder
problem is when
I do have those
specific data, and I'd
like to find a piece
of the network that's
most relevant to
those specific data.
So it could be different
in different settings.
Maybe the part of
the network that's
relevant in the
cancer setting is not
the part of the network that's
relevant in the diabetes
setting.
So one way to think about this
is that I have the network,
and I paint onto
it my expression
data or my proteomic data.
And then I want to find
chunks of the network that
are enriched in activity.
So this is sometimes called
the active subgraph problem.
And how do we find
the active subgraph?
Well, it's not that
different from the problem
that we just looked at.
So if I want to figure out a
piece of the network that's
active, I could just take the
things that are immediately
connected to each other.
That doesn't give me
the global picture.
So instead why
don't I try to find
larger chunks of
the network where
I can include some
nodes for which I do not
have specific data?
And one way that's
been done for that
is, again, the simulated
annealing approach.
So you can try to find
pieces of the network that
maximize the
probability that all
the things in the
subnetwork are active.
Another formulation
of this problem
is something that's called
the Steiner tree problem.
And in the Steiner tree,
I want to find trees
in the network that consist of
all the nodes that are active,
plus some nodes that are not,
for which I have no data.
And those nodes for
which I have no data
are called Steiner nodes.
And this was a problem that
was looked at extensively
in telecommunications.
So if I want to wire up
a bunch of buildings--
back when people used wires--
say to give telephone service,
so I need to figure out
what the minimum cost is
for wiring them all up.
And sometimes, that involves
sticking a pole in the ground,
then having everybody
communicate to that pole.
So if I've got paying
customers over here,
and I want to wire
them to each other,
I could run wires
between everybody.
But I don't have to.
If I stick a pole over here,
then I don't need this wire,
and I don't need this wire,
and I don't need this wire.
So this is what's
called a Steiner node.
And so in graph theory, there
are pretty efficient algorithms
for finding a Steiner graph--
the Steiner tree-- the smallest
tree that connects
all of the nodes.
Now the problem in our setting
is that we don't necessarily
want to connect every
node, because we're
going to have in our
data some things that
are false positives.
And if we connect too
many things in our graph,
we end up with what are
lovingly called "hairballs."
So I'll give you a
specific example of that.
Here's some data that
we were working with.
We had a relatively small
number of experimental hits that
were detected as
changing in a cancer
setting and the
interactome graph.
And if you simply look
for the shortest path,
I should say, between
the experimental hits
across the
interactome, you end up
with something that looks very
similar to the interactome.
So you start off with a
relatively small set of nodes,
and you try to find
the subnetwork that
includes everything.
And you get a giant graph.
And it's very hard
to figure out what
to do with a graph
that's this big.
I mean, there may be
some information here,
but you've taken a
relatively simple problem
to try to understand the
relationship among these hits.
And you've turned it
into a problem that
now involves hundreds
and hundreds of nodes.
So these kinds of
problems arise, as I said,
in part, because of
noise in the data.
So some of these
hits are not real.
And incorporating
those, obviously,
makes me take very long
paths in the interactome,
but also arises because of
the noise in the interactome--
both false positives
and false negatives.
So I have two proteins
that I'm trying to connect,
and there's a false
positive in the interactome.
It's going to draw
a line between them.
If there's a false negative
in the interactome,
maybe these things really do
interact, but there's no edge.
If I force the algorithm
to find a connection,
it probably can, because
most of the interactome
is one giant
connected component.
But it could be a
very, very long edge.
It goes through
many other proteins.
And so in the process of
trying to connect all my data,
I can get extremely
large graphs.
So to avoid having
giant networks--
so on this projector,
unfortunately, you
can't see this very well.
But there are a lot of edges
among all the nodes here.
Most of you have your computers.
You can look at it there.
So in a Steiner tree
approach, if my data
are the ones that are yellow,
they're called terminals.
And the grey ones,
I have no data.
And I ask to try to solve
the Steiner tree problem,
it's going to have to find a
way to connect this node up
to the rest of the network.
But if this one's
a false positive,
that's not the desired outcome.
So there are
optimization techniques
that actually allow me to
tell the algorithm that it's
OK to leave out some of the data
to get a more compact network.
So one of those approaches
is called a prize
collecting Steiner tree problem.
And the idea here
is the following.
For every node for which
I have experimental data,
I associate with
that node a prize.
The prize is larger,
the more confident
I am that that node is
relevant in the experiment.
And for every edge,
I take the edge away,
and I convert it into a cost.
If I have a high confidence
edge, there's a low cost.
It's cheap.
Low confidence edges are
going to be very expensive.
And now I ask the
algorithm to try
to connect up all
the things it can.
Every time it includes a
node for which the zeta keeps
the prize, but it had to add
an edge, so it pays the cost.
So there's a trade-off
for every node.
So if the algorithm wants
to include this node,
then it's going to pay the
price for all the edges,
but it gets to keep the node.
So the optimization
function is the following.
For every vertex that's not in
the tree, there's a penalty.
And for every edge in
the tree, there's a cost.
And you want to minimize
the sum of these two terms.
You want to minimize the number
of edge costs you pay for.
And you want to
minimize the number
of prizes you leave behind.
Is that clear?
So then the algorithm then can,
depending on the optimization
terms, figure out is it more of
a benefit to include this node,
keep the prize, and pay all
the edge costs or the opposite?
Throw it out.
You don't get to keep
the prize, but you
don't have to pay
the edge costs.
And so that turns these
very, very large networks
into relatively compact ones.
Now solving this problem is
actually rather computationally
challenging.
You can do it with integer
linear programming.
It takes a huge
amount of memory.
There's also signal and
message passing approach.
If you're interested in
the underlying algorithms,
you can look at some
of these papers.
So what happens when
you actually do this?
So that hairball that
I showed you before
consisted of a very
small initial data set.
If you do a shortest path
search across the network,
you get thousands
of edges shown here.
But the prize collecting Steiner
tree solution to this problem
is actually extremely compact,
and it consists of subnetworks.
You can cluster
it automatically.
This was clustered by hand,
but you get more or less
the same results.
It's just not quite as pretty.
If you cluster by hand or by
say, edge betweenness, then
you get subnetworks
that are enriched
in various reasonable
cellular processes.
This was a network
built from cancer data.
And you can see things that are
highly relevant to cancer-- DNA
damage, cell cycle, and so on.
And the really nice
thing about this
then is it gives you
a very focused way
to then go and do experiments.
So you can take the networks
that come out of it.
And now you're not
operating on a network that
consists of tens of
thousands of edges.
You're working on a
network that consists
of very small sets of proteins.
So in this particular
case, we actually
were able to go in and test
the number of the nodes that
were not detected by
the experimental data,
but were inferred by the
algorithms of the Steiner
nodes, which had no
direct experimental data.
We will test whether blocking
the activities of these nodes
had any effect on the
growth of these tumor cells.
We will show that
nodes that were
very central to the
network that were included
in the prize collecting
Steiner tree solution,
had a high probability
of being cancer targets.
Whereas the ones that were
just slightly more removed
were much lower in probability.
So one of the advantages of
these large interaction graphs
is they give us a
natural way to integrate
many different kinds of data.
So we already saw that the
protein levels and the mRNA
levels agreed very
poorly with each other.
And we talked about
the fact that one thing
you could do with
those data would
be to try to find the
connections between not
the RNAs and the proteins,
but the connections
between the RNAs
and the things that
drove the expression of the RNA.
And so as I said, we'll see
in one of Professor Gifford's
lectures, precisely
how to do that.
But once you are able to do
that, you take epigenetic data,
look at the regions that are
regulatory around the sites
of genes that are
changing in transcription.
You can infer DNA
binding proteins.
And then you can
pile all those data
onto an interaction
graph, where you've
got different kinds of edges.
So you've got RNA nodes that
represent the transcript
levels.
You've got the
transcription factors
that infer from the
epigenetic data.
And then you've got the
protein-protein interaction
data that came from
the two hybrid,
the affinity capture mass spec.
And now you can put all
those different kinds
of data in the same graph.
And even though
there's no correlation
between what happens in an RNA
and what happens in the protein
level-- or very
low correlation--
there's this
physical process that
links that RNA up
to the signaling
pathways that are above it.
And by using the prize
collecting Steiner tree
approaches, you can rediscover.
And these kinds
of networks can be
very valuable for other kinds
of data that don't agree.
So it's not unique to transcript
data and proteome data.
Turns out there are many
different kinds of omic data,
when looked at individually,
give you very different views
of what's going on in a cell.
So if you take knockout data,
so which genes when knocked out,
affect the phenotype?
And which genes, in
the same condition,
change an expression?
Those give you two
completely different answers
about which genes are important
in a particular setting.
So here we're looking at
which genes are differentially
expressed when you put
cells under a whole bunch
of these different conditions.
And which genes
when knocked out,
affect viability
in that condition.
And then the right-hand
column shows the overlap
in the number of genes.
And you can see the
overlap is small.
In fact, it's less
than you would
expect by chance
for most of these.
So just to drill that home, if
I do two separate experiments
on exactly the same
experimental system,
say yeast responding
to DNA damage.
And in one case,
I read out which
genes are important by
looking at RNA levels.
And the other one,
I read out which
genes are important by knocking
every gene out and seeing
whether it affects viability.
We'll get two completely
different sets of genes.
And we'll also have two
completely different sets
of gene ontology categories.
But there is some underlying
biological process
that gives rise to that, right?
And one of the
reasons for this is
different assays are
measuring different things.
So it turns out, if you
look-- at least in yeast--
over 156 different
experiments, for which there's
both transcriptional
data and genetic data,
the things that come
out in genetic screens
seem to be master regulators.
Things that were knocked out
have a big effect in phenotype.
Whereas the things that
change in expression
tend to be effector molecules.
And so in say, the
DNA damage case,
the proteins that
were knocked out
and have a big
effect on phenotype
are ones that detect DNA damage
and signal to the nucleus
that there's been
changes in DNA damage
that then goes on and
blocks the cell cycle,
initiates DNA
response to repair.
Those things show
up as genetic hits,
but they don't show up as
differentially expressed.
The things that do show up
as differentially expressed,
the repair enzymes.
Those, when you
knock them out, don't
have a big effect on
phenotype, because they're
highly redundant.
But there are these
underlying pathways.
And so the idea is well, you
could reconstruct these by,
again, using the
epigenetic data,
the tough stuff
Professor Gifford
will talk about in
upcoming lectures.
And for the transcription
factors and then the network
properties, to try to build
up a full network of how those
relate to upstream
signaling pathways
that would then include
some of the genetic hits.
I think I'll skip to
the punchline here.
So we've looked at a number of
different modeling approaches
for these large interactomes.
We've also looked at
ways of identifying
transcriptional
regulatory networks using
mutual information,
regression, Bayesian networks.
And how do all these
things fit together?
And when would you want to
use one of these techniques,
and when would you
want to use another?
So I like to think about the
problem along these two axes.
On one dimension,
we're thinking about
whether we have systems of
known components or unknown
components.
And the other one
is whether we want
to identify physical
relationships
or statistical relationships.
So clustering, regression,
mutual information-- those
are very, very
powerful for looking
at the entire genome,
the entire proteome.
What they give you are
statistical relationships.
There's no guarantee of
a functional link, right?
We saw that in the prediction
that postprandial laughter
predicts breast cancer
outcome, that there's
no causal link between those.
Ultimately, you can
find some reason
why it's not totally random.
But it's not as if
that's going to lead you
to new drug targets.
But those can be on a
completely hypothesis-free way,
with no external data.
Bayesian networks are
somewhat more causal.
But depending on how
much data you have,
they may not be
perfectly causal.
You need a lot of
intervention data.
We also saw that they did
not perform particularly
well in discovering
gene regulatory networks
in the dream challenge.
These interactome
models that we've just
been talking about work very
well across giant omic data
sets.
And they require
this external data.
They need the interactome.
So it works well in
organisms for which
you have all that
interactome data.
It's not going to work in an
organism for which you don't.
What they give you
at the end, though,
is a graph that tells
you relationships
among the proteins.
But it doesn't tell
you what's going
to happen if you start to
perturb those networks.
So if I give you the
active subgraph that
has all the proteins and genes
that are changing expression
in my tumor sample, now
the question is, OK,
should you inhibit the
nodes in that graph?
Or should you activate
the nodes in that graph?
And the interactome
model doesn't tell you
the answer to that.
And so what you're going to
hear about in the next lecture
from Professor
Lauffenburger are models
that live up in this space.
Once you've defined a relatively
small piece of the network,
you can use other kinds
of approaches-- logic
based models, differential
equation based models, decision
trees, and other techniques
that will actually
make very quantitative
processions.
What happens if I inhibit
a particular node?
Does it activate the process,
or does it repress the process?
And so what you could
think about then
is going from a completely
unbiased view of what's
going in a cell, collect all
the various kinds of omic data,
and go through these
kinds of modeling
approaches to identify a
subnetwork that's of interest.
And then use the techniques
that we'll [? be hearing ?]
about in the next lecture
to figure out quantitatively
what would happen if I were
to inhibit individual nodes
or inhibit combinations of
nodes or activate, and so on.
Any questions on anything
we've talked about so far?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can you say again
the fundamental difference
between why you get those two
different results if you're
just weeding out the gene
expression versus the proteins?
PROFESSOR: Oh, sure.
Right.
So we talked about the fact that
if you look at genetic hits,
and you look at
differential expression,
you get two completely different
views of what's going in cells.
So why is that?
So the genetic hits to tend to
hit master regulators, things
that when you knock
out a single gene,
you have a global
effect on the response.
So in the case of
DNA damage, those
are things that
detect the DNA damage.
Those genes tend often not
to be changing very much
in expression.
So transcription factors
are very low abundance.
They usually don't
change very much.
A lot of signaling proteins
are kept at a constant level,
and they're regulated
post-transcriptionally.
So those don't show up in
the differential expression.
The things that are
changing in expression--
say the response regulators,
the DNA damage response--
those often are redundant.
So one good analogy is to
think about a smoke detector.
A smoke detector
is on all the time.
You don't wait until the fire.
So that's not going to be
changing in expression,
if you will.
But if you knock it out,
you've got a big problem.
The effectors, say
the sprinklers--
the sprinklers only come
on when there's a fire.
So that's like the
response genes.
They come on only in
certain circumstances,
but they're highly redundant.
Any room will have
multiple sprinklers,
so if one gets
damaged or is blocked,
you still get a response.
So that's why you get this
discrepancy between the two
different kinds of data.
But again, in both
cases, there's
an underlying physical process
that gives rise to both.
And if you do this
properly, you can
detect that on these
interactome models.
Other questions?
OK.
Very good.